the holidays are going to look a lot
different this year
households are stretched and priorities
are different
your money coach lisa chastain joins us
to talk about ways
to have a memorable holiday season
without spending
a ton of money and lisa as always you
have three tips for us
and one is just to be creative when it
comes to technology
that's right that's right i think
there's a lot of pressure
on families during the holidays
especially to make sure that we're
traveling
and that we can see our loved ones and
we know given
everything that's going on with kobud
right now and the uncertainty
now's the time to not only get creative
with technology but you can save some
money on travel
and being stretched financially that's
going to make a big difference so find
find
fun apps find creative ways to make sure
the people that you love
know you love them and that you can
connect with them and create meaningful
experiences without being with them in
person
yeah so creative with technology and
your second tip is to be creative in
general
when it comes to gift giving that's
right make it meaningful
i have a friend who writes poems and
she is selling writing poems for her for
loved ones
where you can go to etsy and find really
great homemade kind of projects or make
things yourself and get them out to
people
those things will go a long way to let
your loved ones know that they're not
alone
and that there are some really memorable
things in their home that make them
think of you
when you're not there and your third tip
is one we learned in the grinch who
stole christmas it's not about the stuff
it's not it's not about the stuff and
research supports that
that quality of experiences rates
higher in spending in spending
surveys saying that people who spend on
experiences
over things rate themselves happier so
just remind yourself of that
this holiday season take the pressure
off of all the stuff
that you may want to buy this season for
people that you love
and make sure that the experiences are
memorable and valuable
that's going to go a long way in 2020
yeah i love that so much because there's
enough pressure already on everybody
this is a way to
just relax a little bit and really enjoy
the holidays
you thank you so much always great
information you can find lisa chastain
on social media